only on CBS this morning we are
revealing the top 10 riskiest scams in
the US according to a new report from
the Better Business Bureau the Federal
Trade Commission says Americans lost get
this nearly 670 million dollars to scams
in 2019 alone that is a lot of money
more than 37,000 were reported to the
BBB the Better Business Bureau and while
that number decreased from 2018 the
median the middle amount of money lost
per scheme rose to 160 dollars 35
percent of people who were exposed to
one of those scams in 2019 lost money
that's one one in three our consumer
investigative correspondent and a Warner
is here to explain more and a good
morning so employment scams are the
biggest one apparently how do those work
you know somebody will say to you hey
listen you could make part-time money
working from home one of these victims
said she was a college student and she
shared her story with the BBB and she
said you know they said the friend told
me oh you can make $300 and then you can
make $300 per per quarter if you just
sign up for this but what they're really
looking for is your personal information
here so they'll say in order to get this
job you have to provide your personal
information like your birthday your
social security number here's how we're
going to pay you and I think a lot of
these employment scams is look you're
not going to get a lot of money for not
working very hard this is sort of a
truism right people want to believe that
they can and they're talking about the
fact that also they've gotten really
what they call into a high-touch
approach in other words instead of just
sending you a quick email that says hey
make money they'll actually engage with
the victims they will actually have them
do some work for the business before
they get paid sometimes they'll send a
check here's your check oh guess what we
overpaid you we need you to send us some
of the money the extra money back of
course the first check is a fake I think
right and then you're actually sending
them real dollars out of your banking
you know lots of employment scams use
the second risky is I was surprised
about this or cryptocurrency scams yeah
and I was surprised to hear this too
because cryptocurrencies I think is
something that people don't really
understand that well we're talking
about Bitcoin and oftentimes I think
what they're appealing to people in is
hey there's this new kind of thing you
can buy Bitcoin and you can maximize
your money or make thousands your money
and people don't really do the research
here's a tip don't invest in something
that you don't understand it's so
interesting that it's really good advice
because they can talk it to you so well
and you're still seeing that going I
don't understand a word you're saying
but it's they say it with such
confidence you think okay right there's
something barbara corcoran I thought did
a really admirable thing and it
admitting publicly that she fell victim
to a scam Toni almost had a similar
experience where the emails off just a
little bit yeah who's most at risk
because you think both Barbara Corcoran
and Tony de cocoa and Katy tur very
savvy very savvy people should is
something admirable as well I think that
they're getting smarter and smarter you
know they're they're not just sending
you the crappy looking phishing emails
they're actually making them look good
and you really have to we went out to
Microsoft I think it was maybe your and
a half ago and they showed us some of
the pages and the emails that are now
coming in because they watch for this
stuff they have a team that does this
and some of them are incredibly
sophisticated and unfortunately as it so
often does with us as consumers you have
to watch out for yourself also keep in
mind we all hate to admit this but
there's a little bit of a greed factor
yeah you know people get excited right I
can get the five grand I can make the
two grand and they kind of want to
believe it because all of us might be
just a little greedy about trying to get
the money but I was surprised by another
thing here too the most profitable for
scammers tends to be these romance scams
Anna and that's not about money scams
right it's about three thousand dollars
be people you know yeah I never
understand sending money to somebody who
you don't know who you haven't met just
because they're telling you sweet
nothings so I mean and let me set this
up for you Gail I actually have a
somebody that I know yeah
who lost two hundred and eighty thousand
dollars to a romance scam okay and this
person was somebody who was a little bit
vulnerable but as they say in the
romance scams one of the main factors a
lot of the people are 55 to 64 and
is loneliness and they want Anna you
know what there's very your again
they're very clever they'll call them on
the phone they develop a phone
relationship with the victim okay you
know the people feel like women second
riskiest scam for women as you see
because they they feel like they've
developed a relationship with somebody
they'll actually say to them on the
phone don't tell your friends and family
about us they'll never understand and
then they start saying well you know oh
flew to South Africa I'm on my way to
you I was not an accident I was in an
accident
my poor my daughter couldn't get out of
the hospital I just need to brand and
then the next time it's well I just need
like four grand yeah you know the next
time it's 300 and by then you think
you've built up a relationship with
someone you don't want to help you if I
have it's just not a real one yeah 111
you want to trust also true thank you
Anna water always good have you here